so President Trump is excuse me
president Trump is deploying the Navy
hospital ship USNS comfort to New York
Harbor and here's the governor of New
York reacting to that today watch this I
spoke to the president this morning
about specific actions the president is
going to take I can tell you he is fully
engaged on trying to help New York he's
being very creative and very energetic
and the president is going to dispatch
the comfort to us it will be in New York
City Harbor it's literally a floating
Hospital which will add capacity and the
president said that he would dispatch
that immediately so each Navy hospital
ship these ships are just amazing and
they come into port in the times of
greatest need they have a thousand beds
operating rooms labs other medical
devices Democratic congressman max Rose
also commended the move saying I'm
incredibly grateful for the quick and
decisive action by the president and
governor to hear our call to deploy the
USNS comfort to New York Harbor so
joining me now exclusively is VA
secretary Robert Wilkie a member of the
White House corona virus Task Force
secretary Wilkie thank you so much for
being here
first of all it's just it's not every
not every night that we sort of show
that kind of bipartisan support and the
spirit of you know working together that
we are seeing right now in this effort
what are your thoughts on that well as
the former Undersecretary of defense for
readiness the Comfort was one of the
things I was responsible for it is a
great asset and it is a great sign of
the president's commitment not only to
his hometown but to being as aggressive
as possible in confronting what he calls
this invisible enemy and I would add
with the comfort you mentioned the 1,000
beds it will have 600 medical personnel
on it doctors nurses psychologists on
the VA side for New York City Martha
we've been in contact with the deputy
mayor we just sent into New York one of
our mobile vet centers to deal
specifically with mental health issues
mental health concern
that make be confronting veterans in in
New York City so it is as you said a
concerted bipartisan effort yeah the you
know one of the things that you point
out is that the response in the VA
hospitals and what you all did to
protect the veteran population in those
hospitals early on has really been sort
of a model for what we're seeing at
other other facilities right yes it has
we we were first but I have to say that
we rehearse these things regularly we
are the nation's response force when it
comes to natural disasters and in this
case epidemics we epidemics we cut off
access to our hospitals for everyone
except the patients we triage people
outside of the hospitals but more
importantly and this is something that
concerns you because of that wonderful
book that you read the people who occupy
are our living centers in our hospitals
are of the World War 2 era for the most
part those who have sacrificed the most
and given the most I had to make a very
difficult decision and cut off visitors
to those most precious citizens that we
have but it was done as a measure to
protect them from the outside we've also
stopped all elective surgeries dental
surgeries all in an effort to keep our
veterans safe inside of our hospitals
that is a tribute to your leadership and
we hope that they are all doing well as
a result of that have you been testing
your population and how is it going yes
we we have tested well over 300 veterans
we have right now 44 who have tested
positive sadly one has passed away a
veteran an older veteran in Portland but
what we are seeing right now
is that the majority of those we have
tested have been able to be quarantined
at home now I expect a surge I take my
cues from dr. Falchi I can't expect that
the numbers will be this low but we have
been aggressive the president demanded
that we be aggressive and we put in
place practice public health measures to
make sure that we can make our Hospital
as safe as possible yeah you know in
terms of what you worry about and you
just you know mentioned the concern
about a surge in terms of supplies in
terms of masks and gloves and all of
that what kind of coordination is going
on you I think have good supplies of
those things can those supplies be
spread around to help some of these
other facilities that don't have what
they need yes so we started planning for
this in February at the at the beginning
of February and we stocked up on things
like ventilators masts protective
equipment and actually by eliminating
things like elective surgery and dental
care we are we are saving the wear and
tear on those assets as we speak
once the president declared a national
emergency then we had access we have
access to the national stockpiles I've
been working today with several private
laboratories to make sure that we have a
steady supply of testing kits we're
doing the same with masks but as part of
our national mission we support the
civilian of civilian America when we are
called upon so we will be able when
called upon to help HHS and FEMA
distributes some of those assets across
the country to where they are needed
you will be called upon we all will be
called upon and we appreciate what
you're doing and we hope that the
veterans in the care of these hospitals
will receive the best care the best care
possible and we thank you very much yeah
and I thank you and I thank you for your
book on Iwo Jima as you know what Nimitz
said a place where uncommon valor was
common and you have you have made it
real again thank you very much secretary
Wilkie good to speak with you tonight
thank you sir
good luck